What we've done is we've,
we've taken $7,500 from every American or
16, 16,500 from every taxpayer
$16,000 from every taxpayer.
And then given some of those taxpayers,
a check for $1,200 that that's, that's not helping.
We taken two and a half trillion dollars and only given
355 billion to small businesses. Where's the rest going?
Same place. It went last time.
Dave Rubin.
And this is the Rubin report joining me today is the founder of the blaze,
the host of the Glenn Beck radio program and the author of the new book,
arguing with socialists Glenn back. Welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thanks, man. How are you?
I'm all right. Uh, you know,
we are in the midst of a zombie apocalypse and I'm in the people's Republic of
California. So I probably have a shorter list than you do, uh, but I'm okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I'm good. I'm glad I,
New York glad I'm not in LA, you know,
move to the center of the country for a reason. And, uh, this would be it,
this would be it.
So I guess the first obvious question here, uh, beyond just the general,
how you doing during Corona is a as a guy who's sort of been in
mainstream media and out of mainstream media and a,
and a trailblazer in new media.
Did you ever think you'd be doing your show from home? Like Dave Rubin,
does his show from home all the time?
I tell you something, Dave, it is cause I've,
I've been in broadcast for like 42 years now. Um,
the technology and what we can accomplish now,
we couldn't have accomplished even 10 years ago. It's phenomenal.
It's really phenomenal. Uh, how,
how the power of the media really is in the hands
of the average person, if they care to take it, it's really crazy.
So how treating you in the middle of the country where you are at
least a little bit kind of safe?
Yeah. Um, it's, it's pretty good. It's pretty good. Uh, it's not New York.
Thank God. Um, uh,
Texas is still free. Thank God. We've got a good, uh,
governor who is not trying to, uh,
tell everybody exactly what to do. Um, uh, you know,
being home with the kids cause I, my kids live next door,
so we're kind of quarantined together. So we've got nine of us, uh,
you know, uh, living at home, which is, this is nice. It's nice.
It's times where you're like, Oh yeah, I gotta get up. I gotta get out of here.
Um, but most, most of it is good. Most of it is good.
So I know we could get into the numbers about Corona and all of stuff. Well,
let's just put that aside,
but let's talk about the thing that I think mostly animates,
almost everything that you and I do, which is, which is freedom and Liberty.
So as we're hearing about lockdowns being extended and just in the last couple
of days, we heard now in LA where I am now,
we're at May 15th and we know it'll go beyond that because it's not like you
just magically flip the switch and suddenly we're all out there again.
And we see this cascading across the country.
How concerned are you that as we just get more and more stuck in our homes,
as we don't go out, as we don't socialize, as we,
as you probably saw in Michigan,
you can't buy seeds at stores to plant your own food.
All of these types of things.
I'm much more concerned about that than I am the virus specifically.
Are you sort of in line with that and what do you make?
Yeah, so I said, um,
back in January,
when we were starting to look at this and I said,
this thing is going to sweep. This looks like 1918. I said,
but it's not what concerns me is not the death rate.
What concerns me is what it will do to the economy and what it can do to
freedom. And I think that's, I think that's turning out to be accurate.
Um, the, uh, what, what the federal reserve has done,
what the government has done, uh,
is unprecedented and it's, you know,
to really fully understand it. Cause the, the,
the system of the free market is so complex.
And while it has taken a beating for the last 20 years,
it is very fragile. Uh,
and it's as if we were all on a seven 47, uh,
brand new, uh, Boeing seven 47. And, and, uh,
the pilot said, you know what? It's going to get really, really bumpy up here.
So what we're going to do,
some of you had maybe one could get a concussion or
die. Um, but there are 400 of us on this plane.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna turn the engines off and right before we
hit the ground, we're going to turn them back on. I wouldn't be for that.
Uh, I would say maybe,
maybe a couple people could bump their head and maybe we could even lose a
couple of people on the plane. I hate to say that,
but nobody's ever turned the engines off in hopes that you
turn them on at exactly the right time before it's just a pile of rubble on the
ground. Um, and that's what they've done.
And I don't know how effective it's going to be. You know,
they're talking about a V economy where they just turn it off and then pump
money into it to preserve it. And then when you turn it back on,
it goes straight back up. It won't, it won't go straight back up.
It can't go straight back up. First of all, you're losing, you know,
80% of jobs that are created are created by the small businessman.
How many of them had enough money just to pay the,
and their rental on their machinery or their, their restaurant.
They're not going to be able to open up. They're open there,
they're running on about a 5% margin.
How many of those restaurants are going to be able to a hold two months
or month and a half then open back up when I don't know about you day,
but I'm not going to be going, running out to crowded restaurants right away.
That's the last thing that people are going to do.
This is going to affect us enormously,
enormously. And there's something else. I, I just go ahead. Go ahead.
No, so with that in mind,
so before we get to some of the stuff that was done wrong, what,
what would be the right thing to do right now?
So if we're concerned about all those small businesses, I mean,
I know you're not necessarily a UBI guy.
You don't want the government to just be handed cash to people,
but what is the right thing to do then in a situation like this?
So I'm not a UBI guy,
and I've done a lot of looking into UBI because I know what's coming with
technology and everything else. And I am,
I'm much more of a futurist than a [inaudible] if you will. Um,
and so I have looked into UBI. It doesn't work. Um,
however, this is a different situation.
I'm not talking about universal basic income, but this is a different situation.
The, the, the crash of Oh eight was caused by many things,
but the government and the banks,
and then stupid people listening to the government and the banks.
That's why that was caused that in greed.
It just caused that thing to melt down. That wasn't my fault.
Why was I bailing out the banks? It wasn't your fault, Dave,
why are you bailing out the banks? This is different. No, nothing.
Anyone did, except for China caused this.
The government turned it off for the first time in history and said,
you cannot go to work. Well,
article five in the constitution says you better get me some money
because you've just destroyed me.
So you have to make me as whole as you possibly can.
So I am for in this particular case,
the government coming up with ways to feed money into the system
and help those at the lowest rung of the
ladder,
including those small businessmen who are just barely making it now you've
destroyed them. Instead, what we've done is we've,
we've taken $7,500 from every American or
16, 16,500 from every taxpayer
$16,000 from every taxpayer.
And then given some of those taxpayers,
a check for $1,200 that that's, that's not helping.
We taken two and a half trillion dollars,
and only given 355 billion to small businesses.
Where's the rest going? Same place. It went last time.
Right? So with that in mind, is,
is this just one of these things where our system is so,
is so broken in so many ways that every time we try to do something to
fix it, we just create more problems. Like we, yeah, we extended.
So we survive 2008, but then we see, we make to, you know,
banks are too big to fail. What do we do? We make them bigger, uh,
that we just create bandaid on top of bandaid on top of bandaid,
when my hope is that,
that this thing is so profoundly different,
that maybe it actually will get people to look at the root causes and think
about it all differently.
Do you think there's any chance or am I just a dreamer?
I think you're a dreamer on that one. Um,
because the damage has already been done and the system has already changed.
I think it's been baked into the response. Um, you know,
the fed had prepared this, this was a prepared response.
Um, you can read it in their own notes. Uh,
they knew exactly what they were doing when they came into the president and he
said, we've got to quarantine the country. What do we do? The fed,
handed him a book and said, here's what we think should be done.
And for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.